[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to "Coffee with a Googler."
I'm here today to talk with
Christine Robson, who's
a research PM for
machine learning.
We're going to talk about what's
new and exciting in the field
of machine learning, including
Project Magenta, which
is all about machine learning
for generating music.
We'll also take a look
at some of the things
that are happening
in Youtube as well as
advances in image recognition.
So that video,
that was an artist
who did a cover of a track that
was generated by a computer.
Is that right?
CHRISTINE ROBSON: Yes, exactly.
So the piano that you
were hearing, that's us.
That's the machine
learned music.
That's the generative
model, the TensorFlow model,
coming up with a piano track.
And then we put this out there
as part of our open sourcing
efforts to put all
this generative music
models that we're doing online.
And these artists, they
listened to the music.
They were interested in it.
They were inspired by it.
And they decided to sort of
jam along with our music track.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Were you
expecting somebody to do that?
CHRISTINE ROBSON: No, we
weren't expecting that at all.
It was really very exciting.
We got all excited
in the office.
We're all passing the video
around, taking a look.
It was really pretty exciting.
But this is what we
hope will happen, right,
that we can use machine
learning for these really
creative purposes and really
get a partnership going where
artists and creators want to
work with machine learning
tools to be more
creative and to have fun.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
I remember you said
something once-- it's not
about replacing music.
It's almost like
inspiring musicians.
CHRISTINE ROBSON: Yeah, exactly.
And something-- you know, Doug,
who's the lead on this project,
he talks about
this all the time,
that it's not that we're trying
to make the best music out
there.
I mean, I'm not even a musician.
It's that we're trying to
make tools that the best
musicians can use, tools that
spur this kind of creativity.
And the Magenta Project,
that's the project that
was open source that we
generated this music from.
The Magenta Project's really
about making those tools
for creators.
Starting with music, but we
want to have tools for creators
to do art generation,
to do videos,
to really tackle all
of these questions
of how can you be
creative and work
with a machine-learned model
to make yourself more creative?
LAURENCE MORONEY: And now,
for this piece of music,
it was-- I recognized the first
bars was like "Twinkle Twinkle
Little Star."
CHRISTINE ROBSON: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
it took over from there?
CHRISTINE ROBSON: Exactly.
So we give it this quick
bar, like [SINGING].
And then the model is
trained over a huge swath
of music-- everything
from Bach to the Beatles.
And it's just trying to predict
what the next note should be.
But it uses a type
of machine learning
called a recurrent
neural network.
So it looks backwards in
time over the music that's
been played already and
tries to predict sequentially
what the next note
should be based on of all
of the music it's seen before.
So you give it just a couple
of notes to get it started,
and then it just takes off.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
CHRISTINE ROBSON: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's pretty cool.
CHRISTINE ROBSON:
It is really cool.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And this
was built with Magenta?
CHRISTINE ROBSON: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And I know you're
the product lead for Magenta.
Could you-- like
if somebody wanted
to get started with
Magenta and maybe
start inspiring other people
in some other kind of art form,
or maybe with music, how would
they go about doing this?
CHRISTINE ROBSON: So everything
from Magenta is online.
We have a GitHub.
It's part of the
TensorFlow project.
So if you go to the
tensorflow/magenta on GitHub,
you can go and you can
download all of the tools.
We encourage everyone to
download, to contribute,
to play with what
we've got there
and see if they can do
something creative too.
I mean, that's why
we've put it out there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
And it's not just music, right?
There are other art forms too?
CHRISTINE ROBSON:
Well right now,
we've been focusing
the project on music.
But the tools are very general.
The tools are really about
generative machine learning,
this idea of generating music,
generating art, the tools
to create rather than
just making predictions
with machine learning.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, cool.
And machine learning, of course,
it's not just incubation.
It's in use in the
real world already,
like things like YouTube are
using it for recommendations.
CHRISTINE ROBSON: When you think
about a machine-learned model
and you think about all
of the possible data they
can go into it and
all of the places
where the signals are
going to come from,
if you can capture more
signals than you might
be able to think of as a
human, you can do better
than a rule-based system.
And there's also this notion
in-- it's a very hard concept
to explain.
There's this notion of
embeddings in computer science
and machine learning
research, where
you put a way to capture all
this information together.
You capture relationships
which aren't easy to describe
by simple, human labels.
Like maybe the relationship
between these two things
is really easy to explain.
You can imagine
writing a rule for it,
like I really like cat videos.
So maybe you'd
say, this cat video
is similar to this
other cat video.
They both contain cats.
They're both from Japan,
something like this.
But then there might
be other factors
that are really hard
for a human to suss out.
Like maybe what I
really like about this
is sort of an abstract
feel about the video,
the way in which I
like watching the cat
jump in and out of the box.
And that kind of
abstract feel translates
to this totally other also
kind of cute video involving
pandas on slides.
And these two
things are related,
but it's hard to put your
tongue on exactly why.
But they're obviously
related, and they're
related for everybody who
looks at these YouTube videos.
And that's something that
a machine-learned model
can capture really
easily, especially
with these embeddings
that we use,
and that it's really hard for
a human to write a rule for.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right, got it.
So it's like if you like
x, you might like y.
And you may not
realize it, but when
you have all these variables
coming out of an LM model
that it can actually
show you that,
and you can actually
learn that about yourself.
CHRISTINE ROBSON: Yes, exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's like
an emergent type thing.
CHRISTINE ROBSON: It does
feel emergent sometimes,
these notions of ideas that you
wouldn't have thought really
mattered for your
preferences-- like things
that I might not have realized
I wanted to see in a YouTube
video, like how I
want to spend my time,
that I really like
this particular niche
kind of cat video.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I've
discovered lots of music
that I like in that
way, where it's
like I'm watching
one piece of music,
and then it suddenly
goes onto something else
on the playlist of
somebody I've never
even heard of in a style that
I probably don't even like.
But hey, that's not
bad, that type of thing.
CHRISTINE ROBSON: Yeah.
And we actually do that.
We do machine learning for
like music list curation.
So actually, the lead
on the Magenta Project,
Doug, his role at Google
before we started this project
was in the music
recommendation system.
He's a musician.
He's got a real passion,
both for machine learning
and for music.
And so we spent a
lot of time working
on how to predict what music
you're going to really enjoy
listening to based on what
music you already like,
and looking not just at a very
simple thing, like which people
like the same kind of music,
but actually analyzing
the structure of the music
and understanding how
different musical pieces are
related to each other in sort
of subtle ways and
fundamental ways,
and being able to really do
very curated playlists for you
to find things that you're
going to be interested in.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So I
understand that YouTube,
it's done so well with
this kind of stuff.
It's even won some awards.
Is that right?
CHRISTINE ROBSON:
Yeah, so you don't
think when you're a computer
scientist that you're
going to be working in a
field that gets an Emmy.
But actually, YouTube won an
Emmy for personalized video
recommendations.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, wow.
CHRISTINE ROBSON: It
was a technical Emmy.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Hey,
an Emmy's an Emmy.
CHRISTINE ROBSON: I know.
It's true.
And this was awarded
because we do
such a good job of personalizing
video recommendations.
When I see that
perfect cat video,
that's because we're
doing such a good job
prioritizing what
you want to watch
and prioritizing how to find
the perfect video for you
in this moment.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So going beyond
like recommendation engines
and that kind of thing,
one of the things I
keep reading about
is how LM is now used
for image recognition
and for attributing images.
And I know you've been
involved in that a little bit.
Could you tell us about it?
CHRISTINE ROBSON:
Yeah, so if you
haven't used the
Google Photos app,
you should use the
Google Photos app.
It's my new favorite thing.
I love that I can
pick up my phone
and ask it to find
me photos of my son,
ask it to find me photos of
my son playing with my cat,
and that it has this
great model where
it knows-- it can
do face detection
and find my son for me.
It can do detection on my
cat and find my cat for me.
And it does this
because we've fed
this model all of the images
we've seen from the web of all
of the different kinds of cats.
And it has this model
built up where it sort of
knows what a cat looks like.
And so it can label
it very effectively.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So one of
things about image recognition
is I remember you had-- I
read something from you even
talking about a cat.
And it could recognize
a cat's face,
even though the cat
didn't have ears.
And the ears are one of the
most distinctive parts of a cat,
right?
CHRISTINE ROBSON:
Yeah, that's my cat.
So a few years ago,
my cat, who lives
in California of course
and suntans all the time,
she got some skin
cancer in her ears.
She's fine now.
But the vet had to remove
her ears to clear the cancer.
And so she looks a
little bit funny now.
She's still really cute,
but she's got no ears.
And she looks less like a
cat than you might imagine.
But our image recognition
software is fine.
It can still recognize
her as a cat.
And so if I ask my phone for
photos of my son and my cat,
it still recognizes that
she's a cat and can find her.
And it's this
flexibility that you
get from training a model
with a lot of different data.
There's not probably
a lot of examples
of cats with no ears on YouTube,
but we can sort of extrapolate
when we use these really
powerful, deep, neural network
models to sort of--
we know basically
what the cat should look like.
And so we can extrapolate
past things like the fact
that she doesn't
have ears anymore.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Aww.
I'm glad she's
doing well, though.
CHRISTINE ROBSON: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
a couple of months
ago, we had Joshua
Gordon on the show.
And there was one thing
that he said to me that I
thought was really fascinating.
And he was talking about
three, four, five years
from now, the skills
of machine learning
and the techniques
will be as important
to developers
as like JavaScript
or SQL are today.
And I think he was right.
And I would love to inspire
people to go out and do more
into this, like learn more
about machine learning,
do things such as
creating music or art,
or who knows what other kind
of things they'll come up with.
And I know you've got
a wealth of resources.
And what kind of
things would you
ask developers to
take a look at?
CHRISTINE ROBSON:
Well, of course
I'm very passionate about this
because machine learning is
my passion.
But I do think
that Josh is right.
We've talked about this a lot.
But thinking about
machine learning
is so different than thinking
about other traditional kinds
of software engineering.
I often make the analogy
that the difference
between functional programming
and object-oriented
programming, that
paradigm shift is
much smaller than
the shift of thinking
about machine learning
versus thinking
about traditional
programming methods.
So the shift is very
big and very important,
and that's why we want
everybody to be together
on it from the beginning.
That's why we're putting so
much effort into open sourcing
our tools.
We're really open sourcing
the best of everything
we've got to try and get
everybody together around this.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
developers in the outside world
kind of already get
the best Google, right?
CHRISTINE ROBSON: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --which
is just mind-blowing
when you think about it.
CHRISTINE ROBSON: Yeah.
And I mean, this is why
we've put so much work
into open sourcing
TensorFlow and why we really
want to put this all out there.
It's so important to think
about what you can do
with machine learning models.
Because I really
think this is going
to be transformative for the
kinds of things we can do.
I mean everything
from YouTube, where
you're predicting the
next video or other angles
you can think of that affect
your sort of day-to-day life,
to these more esoteric, creative
things, like music generation,
things where you really
want to have the best
tools at your disposal,
and you really
want to be able to be
as creative as possible.
And machine learning is going
to enable all of these things.
So we want everybody
to be really fluent.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
I just thoroughly
recommend it for anybody.
Any developers out there, just
go take a look at the sites
that we've linked below.
There's some fabulous
stuff out there,
and you're getting
ready for the future.
So thank you so much, Christine.
This has been awesome.
CHRISTINE ROBSON: Thank you.
It was a real pleasure
chatting with you.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Had a lot of fun.